[inaudible] the Joe Rogan experience.
That's funny. Yeah, we love, we like I, I,
I don't hold grudges like Bobby Lee and
I were talking about Bobby holds the
biggest grudge was on earth. He
has some of the worst. I mean,
he has like 20 year old grudges.
Really? Oh my God. Yeah.
Bobby Lee asked him about it.
He genuinely,
when someone does the wrong thing to him,
like I'm not talking
like makes a bad mistake.
When someone does something where
you're like, that's fucked up,
that can fuck up a friendship.
He will hold that against you for the
rest of time. That's it. That's it.
Where some people would go, whatever, man,
I forgive you. Shit happens now. He's,
he holds a fucking grudge, dude. Bad.
That little tiny ball rice ball has a
lot of fucking vengeance inside of him.
He's my little dumpster. How dare
you? No, I'm allowed to say that, man.
I'm allowed to say that
because I, uh, because I used
to own Bobbie. I used to buy,
bought him for a month.
How much did it cost? 65 grand.
That's a lot. Did you do anything?
Did you have to feed him?
He doesn't really require that much
food and when does he get to own you?
That's part of the deal, right? He
owns you for a month. 10 years later,
10 years later. He owns you for a
whole market with me for a month. Yeah.
Then he's going to be stewing on it for
10 years. Didn't even really did do that.
They just decided, okay, I'll, you
can own me for one month. Yeah,
and I'll do whatever the fuck you want,
but then I own you for one month,
10 years from now. That's a great
movie. By the way. This is a crazy deal.
It's great.
The dog stays alive be well like nine
years later that dude's just drink in and
chain smoke could try to kill trying to
kill us because he is a of fingers slave
for a month. That'd be like
indentured servitude. Right?
Mostly was people that were too poor
to make journeys are too poor to do
something.
So they would give up a certain amount of,
like they would make a contract,
like they would work for someone
for a certain amount of time. Right.
That's essentially how we set up. Yeah. I
mean that's basically what it is, right?
Basically saying like, but it's,
yeah. Is, it's like a slight, I mean,
I guess the condition is probably varied.
You know,
one of the grossest ones I ever saw was,
um,
vice did a piece about a Dubai,
I believe it was, and about,
um, some people who are unscrupulous, uh,
construction people would take these
folks in from Third World countries and
promised them all this money to work
there and then they'd take their passports
away from them and then
pay them a fraction of what
they're supposed to pay for
them so that they're trapped and
they were living in squalor, trapped.
They don't have their passport anymore.
They're in the wrong cumin. Trafficking
is what it is. I mean, that's the same
as when they do to these young girls.
They have these girls come over
the United States, you know, uh,
I think it was a documentary on Netflix
about these like young Russian models,
right? And they give these goals modeling
contracts. They live in, uh, you know,
like a four bedroom apartment, two girls
to a room, right? And they essentially,
you know,
fuck them around for a little while with
small little weird maybe random gigs.
And then they're like, hey, if
you want to make more money,
you could always sell your
body or sell pictures of you.
Nude makes way more money.
And they think it's kind of
part of this modeling thing.
And this is like a content, I think it
was a dot. I think it was on Netflix,
but it was all about these girls
getting trapped and they can't go back.
They don't have enough money.
And this, this modeling agent,
these modeling agencies, these with these
managed manager agencies there, well,
we have to keep your money and we'll
give you like a, a salary, so to speak.
We pay your rent will give you food.
It's horrible.
But if it was dudes, I
wouldn't care at all. Yeah,
of course
it was true.
It was these five handsome guys came over
from Russia looking to get some pussy
and drive Ferrari's,
but it wasn't really working out for them.
But like get a job, get a job.
It's what you use there. Yeah.
The fuck did you think
was going to happen?
You're just going to get pussy
and Ferrari's. Get outta here bro.
I'm good looking.
I thought this would make me make me,
I'm sorry I can't get you any modeling
gays, but if you want to make some money,
fuck this old lady. Sup. So how much,
how much for two grand for me
to fuck that old lady on. Okay.
That's all you gotta do. Do I have to
come or just hang with her for awhile?
She's got go. She has to, she asked. I
have to work with hotel. She come. Yeah.
So you got to work with her. Okay. You
yeah, to be a good act. No eating pussy.
I can't do that. Oh, you have to eat
a pussy. I have two, three grand.
They don't even shave old
ladies. They gave up. Okay.
So eat Harry Bush for two grand,
three grand, three grand. The lesson.
Right.
How much sympathy would you have for
that or wants to show Gigolos that was on
showtime. I didn't, but I
know Shab watched it. I know
time and Christina loved it.
They talked about a lot.
Why is it that shop there on the right
and so I don't they stick it ran its
course. It was on flight 17. Oh
No, it was not on for 60 g's. Yeah,
I'll toss interviewed one
of the guys I believe.
What kind of way,
by the way,
every TV show I've done is only gone for
like two years, but Gigolos gets six.
That's the state of television. Jesus
Christ. That is crazy. That's a very,
that's a very good tell by the way.
There's like not a lot of these, these uh,
this whole like the culture of male
Gigolos I think they said percentage wise
it's like unbelievably smaller.
These guys that get into the Gigolo world
and stay, they all get, they get in,
they get out.
Most women that get into sex work last
significantly longer than these dudes.
Way, way long for very,
you know, varied reasons,
but I think the Gigolo thing is kind of
like a moment in a man's life where he's
like, I want to fucking try it some
young like fun, loving free for all.
It's like open mind. I'll just give
it a whirl. Then he gets right out.
I don't think that happens for girls
at all. I think women stay in second.
Would you feel bad for some dude who
was working as a Gigolo in his pimp was
shook night and pimp was
making them go out there.
Eat that pussy now to make that money.
It's the website for it.
I just got a website for it. Yeah, that's
that guy writes really good poetry.
This guy,
what's going on in our money?
What's going on with him at the coffee
shop around the corner from my house.
Why is he wearing at Charlotte? Thought
that's just how it says. Look Dude,
Bradley, Lord Nick. Hey Man,
I ain't Hayden. If you could
slink Dick and get paid,
good luck to you. Look, some people do it.
Some people out there working as a misuse
that do not like touching people. Okay.
Tell me how much different that is.
That's a bummer though.
How much different is that then?
Being able to be a guy on wear.
Nice shirts like that and
occasionally got a bank broads.
You don't want to wear a nice shirt. It's
so horrible. Look, you get some natural,
no, fuck. The world could be worse.
Do you remember Richard Gere?
Wasn't he a Gigolo in one of his movies?
Who isn't it?
Didn't you have a movie called Gigolo?
We'd like bang old ladies.
I don't know if it was called Gigolo,
but yeah,
I think it was called Gigolo Americans.
American Gigolo. That's right.
I'll let you, boy, you
must've loved this shit. Yeah.
You know she gives out there banging
ladies. Here's what they don't tell you.
Most of that money and that Gigolo
world is sucking Dick. Okay?
If you want to go out there and suck
that Dick, you can make that money,
but if you just want to bang old ladies,
ah, whoa. Look at the difference.
That's when he was young.
That's when he was held up.
We gotta be like 2123 he was
pretty young and handsome,
and then father time done. Fucking
Molly whopped him all the time. Got Him.
Marvin Hagler on Thomas Hearns
third round.